um
but i will say watching
watching john krasinski
uh
on wires uh flailing his arm
as he's shredded was was also a lot of
fun it doesn't look fun does that look
fun at all
i love that they actually i know
the filmmaking process is just it is how
these things are made but just the idea
of they put jim
jack ryan on these wires in this green
screen and sam raimi just said now
scream now scream now your body string
cheese okay it hurts it hurts more than
anything you've ever experienced scream
bulge your eyes out john do it jim do it
i like to think that raymie is uh
secretly dwight uh with a mask on yeah
seed controlled me jim
do this jim it's my office now jim
he does the fake run
[Laughter]
uh and a a huge huge thanks to the whole
ringer verse team yeah joanna robinson
mallory rubin for getting that great
interview clip from uh from michael
waldron
great dude love that dude he's such an
amazing interview guest and their
amazing uh podcast host listen to
everything from the ring reverse that's
it's such a huge part of how i digest
all these marvel
properties and everything uh so i
learned so much from just like listening
to them
and uh and yeah let's talk about it
welcome back to new rock stars the
fantastic four made its mcu debut in dr
strange in the multiverse of madness
followed quickly by its mcu adieu
john krasinski reed richards mr
fantastic of dimension 838 was unraveled
into string cheese of course but we are
now finally learning exactly how that
christine cameo came to be whether
krasinski will return to play reed
richards again son of a wretch
[Laughter]
i screamed so hard my earbud popped
right out
this is inside marvel new rockstar's
weekly marvel reaction show and this
week we are talking about the fantastic
four in the mcu i'm eric boss here with
me is mt dude we are finally here we
have been waiting for reed richards for
years now in the mcu anyway and finally
we got the fan cast of all fan casts
john krasinski as reid richards i'm
happy
the world dreams came true and a moment
later it was a night we've all wanted
the fantastic three and it's finally
here
but you know what's crazy now all these
interviews from sam raimi michael
waldron everybody have finally confirmed
how exactly john krasinski was cast in
this film how they originally considered
james bond actor daniel craig for this
cameo
in the studio's plans for reed richards
in the future are one of these two
actors gonna be playing them are they
gonna go with a different actor for this
fantastic four movie that's coming up in
the pipeline we'll talk about that but
first be sure to check out all of our
merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com there's a bunch of
cool shirt designs based on doctor
strange and multiverse of madness as
well as some other merch items including
some adorable garganto stickers and you
can still grab number 15 in our latest
obsession line of shirts shattered
madness support the awesome work we do
here at new rockstars and check out all
of our merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com all right mt what are
we talking this week on inside marble oh
bro we gotta ask it will john krasinski
himself return as reed richards in the
future mcu fantastic four movie what do
you think
well various interviews in recent days
have revealed the multiverse of madness
producer's intent by casting john
krasinski in the role of reed richards
talking with variety screenwriter mike
waldron said that he worked closely with
sam raimi to bring reed to life but was
not involved with the casting and he
said the question of his return is
really a question for somebody else that
said in other other interviews that it's
above his pay grade but an interview
with the la times director sam raimi
confirmed that cask and kriszinski came
directly from kevin feige raimi said
quote he thought it would be great
because the fans had out of nowhere
online chosen john as the choice to play
reed if they ever made a fantastic four
movie i think was some straw
i think it was some straw poll that had
just appeared and people voted and
waldron added kevin understood that was
the online head canon and it felt like a
cool way to make that dream come true
and then turn it into a nightmare
now when asked about the krasinski
casting moon knight head writer jeremy
slater told comicbook.com i think
krasinski is a really cool choice if
that's who they go with for whoever the
real version of reed that gets
introduced i think he'd be an awesome
choice we didn't get to see him do a lot
of fun stuff in there it was more of an
introduction and sort of a glorified
cameo right now in all of these
interviews walter and raymie have
confirmed that wanda killing all of the
illuminati was something in waldron's
first draft of that screenplay waltran
said that it was not and in the outlines
or the previz that they did for the
movie waldron wrote it into the
screenplay draft with no knowledge of
who they would cast as reed richards it
was just really a kind of let's see
if they let me keep this in and sam
raimi read it and loved it feige
approved it and then it sounds like
feige then said hey let's put krasinski
in there as a nod to the fans who wanted
krasinski to play this role and then
we'll crush their dreams moments later
oh boy uh
furthermore we learned that uh elizabeth
olsen she did this amazing lie detector
oh i love that video so much
yeah it's so great it uh she said and
it's confirmed from the lie detector
test that she never met john krasinski
she's never met the guy she she never
shared a set with him confirming that
what we all thought krasinski's cameo
was shot on a private green screen set
to you know keep spoilers from getting
out and uh olson was not there for that
shoot this is something that was done
late in the production process maybe on
reshoots which would explain why these
other actors in that scene don't really
react with the horrified reactions one
would have if they watch their friend's
head implode or another friend gets
shredded into string cheese
and we also learned from deadlines
justin kroll that krasinski wasn't even
the first choice to play reed richards
but they originally wanted daniel craig
but that when there was an uptick of
covet
cases craig backed out he was living
with he was living with his family in
london didn't want to expose himself or
his family by traveling to the us to
shoot this scene so to me the fact that
they were considering the james bond
actor and then went with amazon's jack
ryan slash you know everyone's jim
halpers uh to be you know he was the top
fan cast choice suggests that casting
krasinski was more of a one-time stunt
by feige as opposed to like an indicator
of their actual future plans for the
character like if patrick stewart and
anton mount aren't meant to be seen as
the front men of those franchises and
future mcu titles i don't think we're
necessarily meant to see john krasinski
as the mcu reid richards from here
forward but that doesn't mean that
that's not going to be the case either
like people obviously still love john
krasinski in this role not everyone
loves him but he seems to be a very
popular choice and uh you know we now
have this idea of variants one the 838
reed richards has died but there are
countless other variant futures out
there where he could still play a living
reed richards um
i thought it was interesting how they
showed reed entering uh the frame
through this square shaped portal right
just definitely evokes the way the tba's
time door is open and loki it's a
different color but the shape and the
glow of it it just suggests that reed's
tech might be later built upon by his
descendant nathaniel richards akang aka
huey remains when he uses tech to build
the tva uh i don't think we have to read
into john at the majors race versus john
krasinski's race these relatives are a
thousand years apart we also don't know
what other variants of kang or variants
of reed richards will look like the mc
reed can really be any race so setting
aside how uh feige looked at daniel
craig and johnsinsky as deliberately
martyr versions of reeds uh which of
these two mt do you think would be the
better reed richards if one of them is
going to be the actual frontman uh front
man in a future mcu fantastic four as
variants from universes other than a38
and if not those two what actors do you
think would make great variants of reed
richards to lead this upcoming mcu
fantastic four film yeah i i don't i
don't
feel myself personally that daniel craig
would make the best fit for mr fantastic
i don't know i i i personally don't see
it um and i did hear rumors that he
could have been cast as balder the brave
um and i heard that too that that might
have been enough i'm like well that's
like obviously just a rumor not
confirmed um but like yeah so like i
would love to see
um john krasinski come back and like it
would make sense for marvel studios to
bring back princess considering that
they just introduced this character and
that you know the 2015 fantastic four
film still exists and some people still
saw it and so a lot of people
you know still have them as like all
right where's this team like we're doing
multiverses so like where's this team so
like it would i mean is anyone empty
asking where milestones not really
to be honest
but like you know i just feel like
introducing yet another variant after we
just got these two would be kind of
confusing for a lot of people so i think
that kevin feige you know and with that
quote of him knowing that the fan demand
was for john krasinski and like you know
people even though
this reed richards did kind of approach
the situation in a very not smart way if
people do want to see more john
krasinski and like the whole i want to
see the fantastic family like all of
them all six of them just like just
wrote like just roaming about like we
sort of teased in in a multiverse of
madness so yeah i think that
it's going to be john krasinski however
if if it's not going to be john
krasinski i've been a big fan of why am
i blanking on his name
um my god how big of a fan could you be
if you're blanking on his name
okay
i think dennis from from always sunny
but i keep getting his actual oh oh ra
um not rob mcelini rob mcelini plays mac
dennis is uh glenn howard there we go
yeah glenn howerton i forgot his name
because i heard that guy's a dick in
real life that's just
all the personal examples i i know
people who know people who worked for
him and he was kind of a dick oh no
that's just personal anecdotal evidence
i'm not saying i'm not trying to cancel
the guy i'm just
he he looks apart i'll give you that
reid richards is uh he's he's kind of
that as a
personality you're not wrong you're not
wrong
actually empty let's talk about this
what uh characteristics are we looking
for with reed richards and zu what
character qualities what appearance
ticks what mannerisms what uh
psychological like this dude for me
anyway i i feel like a good reed
richards has to be
obsessed with science and like you know
to a really detrimental degree to like
to the point where like he ignores his
his family and his kids he prioritizes
science over them and um i feel like
that that dynamic between like choosing
your family over what you love to do is
something that i really love to see in
fantastic four comics and so like yeah
that obsessed obsession with science but
like also treating it like a like sort
of like a an astronaut film like sort of
like the the ant-man films are an
astronaut film but they're more heisty
astronaut films and you're going down
whereas the fantastic four go upwards
into space so like i would love to see
like a family
adventure
space maybe even multiverse film where
these families just adventuring on these
um like really wild um just cosmic
adventures and that's why they haven't
been here in the mcu but what do you
what do you think what do you want to
know you tap into such an important part
of reed richard's character mt
the obsession because like yeah i think
a lot of us can agree reid richards is
definitely a nerd a lot of people feel
that it'd be great if he was played by a
slightly older actor kind of a daddy
energy a zaddy yeah a big old daddy or
daddy
zaddy or daddy uh i could go either way
on that but a bit of a bit of salt in
that pepper in the hair i don't i don't
have a problem with it that's why i like
john krasinski in the role you know he's
he's a dude who's like but he's probably
in his 40s now right uh and i don't mind
daniel craig in that role i think daniel
craig can play that it's just when you
see daniel craig like in interviews uh
he is a thespian he's got like this
christoph waltz energy to him um he's
like a kind of a goofball so i i think
he could play different roles in the way
that christine can play different roles
but there is an obsession that is
missing from both of them you don't
imagine either of them would say no to
hanging out with their kids and i think
you need to see that he's a reed
richards is a tinkerer in fact this is
why i love re-watching classic films
watch
uh close encounters of the third kind
richard dreyfuss his character is
exactly what we're looking for from reed
richards someone who is almost unlikable
and i love watching uh close encounters
the third time because it's like 70s
spielberg before spielberg started
making every single one of his movies
about the fact that he's a dad
and uh and he's even said later he's
like if i shot uh close encounters like
in the 80s or 90s it would have been a
very different film richard dreyfuss's
character
loses his mind it is a story about
obsession uh when you are uh
met from some kind of supernatural force
either from another dimension or from
another realm or from another planet
and
it suddenly forces you to
recontextualize everything that was
important to you including your own
family your wife your kids
uh and that is a story of close
encounters it you do not like his
character by the end of that movie
you're kind of like you're a dirt bag
you're ruining your family right now i
think there is a tragic aspect to reed
richards that could really be explored
by
a an obsessive nerd uh
to that uh extent i uh a lot of people
have been throwing around names like deb
patel
uh henry golding and i think they could
totally play that nerd that academic
mindset to them um but the tragic nerd
i'm interested in actors like john david
washington
hamish patel
watch station 11 if you can on hbo
hamish patel
crushes that role he is
so hard to connect with but your heart
breaks when you watch him on screen and
can play that
uh
that just that inability
to connect but that
that desire to connect
uh but he has that bird's eye view of of
the context which makes him
weirdly apt to survive the the crisis
and the disasters of station 11.
but
also kind of hard to connect with and i
think
he plays that really well i've thrown
out uh in the past william jackson
heartburn from right now i do want to
see that myself i think he'd be
excellent as well i mean the guy's got a
body for a superhero too yeah let's be
honest
but he's also a nerd who is like you can
imagine him tinkering and people are
just trying to connect with them but he
is alone in his basement just like
branching out the multiverse trying to
connect with multiversal versions of
himself i think it's very important to
see the dna of who uh his descendant
nathaniel richards will become right uh
like the worst case version of that but
you need to see the dna of that
obsession in this character i'm really
glad you brought that up empty oh yeah
for sure william jackson harper would
would literally knock it out of the park
as reed richards though i i do want to
see i just this just popped up in my
brain just now eddie redmayne um i think
he would really do a really great job
because like uh he was in um the theory
of everything right was that eddie
redmayne yeah yeah and like so like he's
got that like same kind of
science and like he kind of has the
builds for uh reed richards i think it'd
be really fun to see eddie redmayne just
just go crazy with reed richards yeah
and if we're gonna go older into like
daniel craig's generation i really think
like
andrew lincoln has been thrown out there
yeah he's definitely got more more salt
and pepper in that beard but like
watching him on the walking dead how
obsessive rick gets about
following his uh his philosophy even
when it's like problematic for his
community like every community
those people the survivors join it's
like why alexandria do not open your
gates to these people
you're all going to die if you let rick
and his friends in and that's kind of
like
the risk of reed richards is he is a guy
who is just trying to find uh in like a
chaotic world a safe haven uh and i
think it often leads his his loved ones
off cliffs
so i think andrew lincoln could play a
really cool version of that but i think
uh more than anything more than just
like the nerdy quality more than just
that wholesomeness that we want to see
from reed richards uh the obsession i
think is there more than any other
marvel character uh like we've seen
nerds before we've seen tony stark as a
paranoid futurist before but tony stark
is not nearly as obsessive as reed
richards is uh like they're they're
definitely risk taking they're
definitely daredevils in certain ways
like nerdy daredevils in the sense of
like i am going to build something it
may blow up everything but i don't care
um
but i think uh reed richards on a
multiversal plane is is that aspect
expanded exponentially 100
well let's talk about uh anson mount and
black bolts role in this movie and uh
what that tells us about maybe other
universes the 616 mcu is branching out
too but first we want to thank helix
sleep for sponsoring this episode when i
dreamwalk across the multiverse i do it
from the comfort of my very own helix
mattress no matter what nightmarish
scenario my mind is transported to my
body rests peacefully and comfortably in
this universe on a mattress from helix
helix sleep has a quiz that takes uh
just two minutes to complete and matches
your body type and your sleep
preferences for the perfect mattress for
you they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot mattresses
great for spinal adjustment to prevent
morning aches and pains both empty and i
have helix mattresses we love them so
just go to helixsleep.com inside marvel
take their two minute sleep quiz and you
will get matched to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk free they'll even pick it up
if you don't love it helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helix sleep.com inside marvel again
that's helixsleep.com
inside marvel we also want to thank
upstart response in this episode we've
all been hit by unexpected expenses or
bills before right and in times like
that it's normal to not know where to
turn luckily upstart is here to help
upstart powered personal loans can help
you pay down high interest debt all
online with simple and easy to
understand payment terms upstart has
helped over 1.8 million customers on
their path to financial freedom whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date rather than
looking at just your credit scores alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income your employment other
information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan check your rate in minutes
for loans between one thousand and fifty
thousand dollars without impacting your
credit score you can even receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan so don't wait and
check your rate today at upstart.com
marvel that's upstart.com marvel to
check your rate today don't forget to
use our url to let them know that we
sent you loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.commarble
all right um
black bolt actor onson mount tweeted
finally able to discuss this without
providing too many spoilers getting the
call from kevin feige was one of the
most unexpected of my life it was an
honor and joy to finally work with sam
raimi who reached out to engage me on
how best to do this beyond grateful for
the experience head exploding emoji
barry the emoji game
a chef's kiss
um but mt i wanted to ask you do you
think black bolts cameo and multiverse
of madness could mean the abc marvel
series like in humans as well as agents
of shield and agent carter could finally
be considered mcu canon absolutely like
as soon as i saw anson mount like his
face i was like you know what finally
like agents of shield is canon somewhere
within the mcu multiverse it's not canon
within the main timeline that we uh
we're living in i don't believe i don't
think that you know um the humans or
ages of shield were factoring into the
overall um
scope of like what's going on within the
american government and all that stuff
that never happened in the main mcu i
think that what we're going to see in
like shows like loki uh maybe even
quantum mania possibly that um you know
characters like fan favorite characters
like quake agent coulson um you know
like all of them like the fitzsimmons
like they're all gonna come back and
just be like hey um
here's we're gonna cross over eventually
or get we're coming to secret wars um
because like we all know that secret
wars is coming and that the marvel
live-action universe has had so many
different faces and like one of the most
beloved and like
my personal favorite is the agents of
shield like i love agents of shield a
lot and like actually one of the first
times i cried at a uh
on a piece of media ever um was when uh
during the uh spies goodbye scene of
agents of shield i was like oh man i'm
gonna miss you this is so sad um because
i love you know that whole team and like
they're just i don't know like this is a
weird
vibe like you after so many seasons
she's like all right that's a it's a
marvel family there so just be really
great to see them pop up in loki which
is i feel like an appropriate show for
them to pop up there but yeah what do
you think about what this means with
ants and mountain black bolts and
being humans yeah someone tweeted me uh
hoping that that seventh seed on the
illuminati dais could actually be uh
phil coulson from another universe or
from the e38 universe i would love that
i love that idea
like by the end of that series
especially colson was such like an elder
uh and and you know my thinking is from
ages of shield final season
they've already been mcu canon at least
within the multiverse like it's still
not sure exactly within the 616 timeline
you know it that's that has not been
answered yet empty you know you know the
two of us are gonna get some some
crazies on twitter yelling at us for not
wholesale adopting every single episode
of agents of shield as mcu cannon
nothing will be good enough for the
agents of shield stands i think the
agents of shield stands on twitter are
becoming the worst [ __ ] yeah they
can they can
definitely be uh pretty
it won't be it's not enough that we just
say it's in the multiverse they're like
no it was in the 616 timeline how dare
you how dare you destroy my fandom how
dare you insult me like they are so
triggered by everything yeah they're
very passionate about that agents of
shield um but like yeah it is but hey we
love edges of shield too and i and i
love that final season i love how they
use the quantum realm and the timeline
logic they they answered more about
timeline logic than avengers end game
did which i have to just applaud the
agency shield for doing that so
absolutely they exist in the multiverse
let's just be happy with that yeah you
know it's really good news
they're going to cross over eventually
yes absolutely and uh especially when
they introduce the fact that black bolt
is the keeper of the terrigen mist the
fact that they said keeper the terrigen
mist is so so important because it
establishes the logic by which the
inhumans exist and uh the way quake was
created right um you know from daisy to
quake uh being wrapped in the terrigen
cocoon and getting her powers like
that's now msu cannon within the
multiverse and within the 838 universe
inhumans exist harrage and myths exist
and it could even just the fact that
they introduced that term i think that's
enough to even say that it could exist
in the 616 universe part of me is
holding out hope that miss marvel brings
in the terrigen mist into that world and
i know i'm sounding crazy but when you
watch the miss marvel trailer there is
just a lot of fog they have a lot of
mist now it may just be uh an aesthetic
choice the director that show just gets
a fog machine and like
action fog cue fog okay great cool but
i'm like there's a lot of fog here some
of that could be territon
we don't know yeah but i would just love
even if that even if that's not how
kamala khan gets her powers i i would
just love if they introduce the concept
of territon mist um right i think it is
a cool
texturally different aspect of the world
that i think we need to see on screen uh
in in live action oh yeah i definitely
feel like yeah that was one of my
biggest um well the happiest things that
i was about um when i was watching
multiverse of madness was the target
miss mentioned because like it is huge
and i think that this in my opinion
anyway
this sort of means to me that miss
marvel will eventually have her comic
book accurate powers she just needs that
terrigen um catalyst to activate you
know whatever like rainbow powers that
she has in the show will probably be
like actually embedded within her dna
which will allow her to do the similar
thing but with her actual skin and bones
and make it really grossly
so you think it's going to be something
that's already in her
biology as opposed to something external
i i honestly feel like you know the the
energies that she's using in the show
will end up being part of her biology
when she does come in contact with the
terrigen mist i think that she will
eventually find these terrigen myths and
like we know from spider-man far from
home that there are cree uh sleeper
cells on earth and like that's right
that's sort of how the inhumans sort of
got things going was because of cree
intervention on earth in early society
messing with humanity and trying to make
people better so for all we know those
sleeper cells that they refer to them as
could be entire in human societies
almost uh maybe run by a decree because
like that's sort of what sort of happens
for a little bit anyway in the comics um
so yeah i i feel like that these
terrigen mists are coming to the mcu and
they're going to factor into
um miss marvel's evolution pro most
likely after the marvels i feel because
i feel like the marvel's is like sort of
explaining it's gonna be like the
rainbow movie it's like it's it's
bioluminescence the movie it's like
glowing girl let's do it and then after
that it's like all right here's here's
miss marvel and like we just wanted to
explain how her powers worked um before
we actually transformed her um outright
so anyway i like how your brain works mt
and i i'm yeah i hope that chris sleeper
cell line gets justified at some point i
assume secret invasion is gonna dig into
a lot of that you know i think we're
going to have curl sleeper cells and
crease sleepers i'll say there's a huge
shadow war that's been going on on earth
and several other planets between it's
like you know the americans right like
there was the cold war was not that cold
there were spies murdering each other
and murdering people and murdering
intelligence officers and i think that's
what's been happening in the secret
invasion i think there's been a shadow
war going on uh and
yeah i i'm just wondering still it seems
like based off of that trailer that
kamala khan gets her powers from these
bracelets right and it seems like it's a
bit of cree tech you know i just don't
know if mist is gonna be part of it it
seems like we put on these bracelets
it's almost like a ten rings kind of
thing or some other kind of bling some
other kind of jewelry or apparel we put
on and i'd much prefer if it if it's not
the mist i'm it's not the end of the
world right i just think like mist
should get introduced if it doesn't uh
create kamala khan's powers
i would hope that someone whether it's
like you know cameron maybe he that's
where he gets he gets hit with the mist
you know and he becomes his comic
version of the hero that he is um i
don't know if it's gonna be given to her
by skrulls or by cree i think kree are
gonna be the bad guys of the crease girl
war in the mcu absolutely um so
yeah i think it's going to be suggested
that the way uh carol danvers got her
powers the source is going to be cree at
the end of the day yeah i believe the
actual medium of it will remain to be
seen but hey why don't we leave it there
for this episode of inside marvel i
can't wait to uh to talk more about miss
marvel with you and uh with other people
on the channel nt it's going to be a
very interesting world i think we have a
release date for she-hulk coming later
this summer yes
so it's we got a bright future ahead uh
here at inside marvel uh don't forget to
check our great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me at ea boss
follow mt at mastertainment subscribe to
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcast thank you all for watching bye
bye guys
you